So a useful thing to know about a social network
is whether everything is connected to everything else
or whether there's some subset of nodes that's isolated
from the main body of nodes.
To put it in another way: whether any given pair of nodes in the network
can communicate by passing messages
from friend to friend, from one place to another.
So this graph is actually separated into two different components.
We'll call them A and B,
where A has three nodes and B has five nodes.
In this case we can do it just by looking at it,
but sometimes this problem is easier and sometimes it's harder.
So it's good to have an algorithmic approach so that the computer
can do it on our behalf.
Just to make sure you understand, here's another graph.
How many disconnected components are in this graph?
If every node can communicate with every other node
by passing messages along the green links,
then you should put one.
If there's actually two separate groups of nodes within each group,
they can communicate but between them they can't, then put two.
If there's three such groups, put three, and so on.
Just write it in the box.